[Music]
how secure is the november election
election officials say measures are in
place to prevent problems
but what about law enforcement the
i-team's vanessa murphy talked with the
head of the fbi las vegas division
that voters may be dropping off their
mail-in ballots at early voting
locations like this one or
casting their ballots at these locations
and there's a lot of misinformation
floating around about this election the
head of the local fbi office says
voters should feel confident though and
any issues will be
investigated because of the robust
protections for voting here in nevada
it's really hard to get away with
anything president donald trump
continuously questions the integrity
of the november election even saying
governor steve sisilak will steal it
one concern mail-in ballots election
officials insist
signature verification helps eliminate
voter fraud
is it widespread in nevada i wouldn't
say it's widespread
i would say that we get reports every
year every election cycle
of potential voter fraud situations and
we investigate them thoroughly
and we hold the people if it's if it's
proven then we hold them accountable
through the u.s attorney's office
as the i-team has reported data reveals
only two votes in nevada have been cast
illegally since 2008.
rouse says the fbi will investigate any
allegations of fraud or voter
intimidation now
and on november 3rd he also tells the
i-team he has confidence in the voting
machines
since they are not part of a network and
have no internet connection
were there attempts to hack into our
system here
you can't do it vanessa you cannot hack
into the nevada
voting machine system you just can't do
it one hundred percent
you would have to you would have to go
machine by machine
and that is just not feasible what is a
concern interference
from abroad foreign adversaries from
multiple countries
are keen on undermining people's
confidence in the election
and so they do that utilizing social
media the internet
and they put out sometimes it appears to
be
legitimate stories or they put out memes
that people
glom on to that make them think that the
elections
somehow going to be illegitimate
president trump has suggested voting
twice by mail
and in person to test this system rao
says don't do that
it's a crime vanessa murphy 8 news now